not a make of Matt it's actually a
there's a protein shake put a little bit
out of it when I run it's a little out
of it but this Kingsman trailer dropped
today I shake on my beard and funny
enough with your livestream yesterday
where we talked about like over
underrated movies and I kind of wish I
mentioned the Kingsmen movies is I feel
like they're actually very underrated
and also Happy Father's Day to all the
fathers out there and to everyone who
has a father most likely you do with
that in mind I'm gonna tell you my
favorite joke from my father when he was
alive it is a joke I've said many times
in this channel and it's coming at you
again how did Captain Hook die he wiped
his ass with the wrong hand let's watch
this trailer people
[Music]
this is going to be soft
man Matthew Vaughn I love the way he
directs action wowie
this feels like Kingsman
Djimon Hounsou
[Music]
welcome to the club it's football
[Music]
restless Rasputin ick more historical
fiction than ever now
[Music]
yes man
Jah man it was great it was great gotta
love those kind of fight scenes where
smaller a guy can't take on giant man
coming after you know what I mean okay
so I don't really remember the other two
trailers that we got all that well but I
remember the marketing of it didn't
really feel like it was a Kingsman movie
and I know that has a lot to do with the
fact that this is a prequel this is
taking place at a much older time but
the vibe and them capitalizing on all
the action sequences here felt a lot
more like Kingsman and even the humor
included and I know with this actor
Harris Dickinson I believe that's the
right one Harris Dickenson it seems like
from what I recall from the last
trailers that his character is kind of
the eggsy position and refines his
character is a little bit more like
Harry Colin Firth's positioned but in
the trends that we've been getting it
doesn't look like this Harris Dickinson
character is going to be the main
character it looks like ray Fiennes will
actually be the main character whereas
the first Kings movie that was kind of
reversed but Colin Firth was a star but
it was really actually Smoove II this
really feels like this will be ray
Fiennes movie ultimately and that being
said I mean it would be cool if this did
open up more doors for Harris Dickenson
I'm not that familiar with this guy's
workers fandom base necessarily however
you know thinking about the role of Xing
with a different Taron Egerton
Edgerton correct me in the comments from
a boy Taryn what that did for him and
how that put him on the map and made him
a star I'm always happy when there could
be a success story to come from a
relatively not as well-known actor to
have a chance to get more fame so maybe
this role will be just as special for
him I doubt it at this point just based
off the marketing it looks like it will
be more ray Fiennes heavily focus it
would be cool if that we did get a nice
surprise out of this character that
Harris Dickinson's playing similar to
how we got a pleasant surprise with
Taron Egerton and also Stanley Tucci
supposed to be in this movie as well I'm
excited for that I mean Stanley Tucci
he's a fantastic fantastic actor for
some reason I don't know maybe because
they kind of look alike I feel like he
be a good supplement for the mark strong
Merlin character in this movie I have no
idea again there's a time stamp of
Stanley Tucci here in the trailer please
let me know thinking about how ray
Fiennes kind of reminds me of the Colin
Firth character Harris Dickinson kind of
reminds you the eggsy character at least
the position my mind keeps telling me
that Stanley Tucci will be sort of the
Merlin like character because they both
look similar to each other that are in
Rasputin into the mix honest I don't
remember if that was established in the
other two trailers for me but that's
cool I like x-men first class a movie
helm by Matthew Vaughn he did a great
job doing this comic book x-men world
and mixing it in with like real life
history and historical fiction and the
historical figure rescued and not gonna
act like I actually know a [ __ ] ton
about this guy really does well he's a
real life person his history has been a
bit mythologized right yeah that's a
work mythologized I think it is some
believed he had like healing abilities
major influence over like Russian royal
family I'm not mistaken feel free to
correct me the man was executed he was
gunned down so I'm wondering if they'll
actually try to include that in this
story if maybe they'll hone in or
capitalize a bit upon things that I
mythologized this Rasputin person I mean
obviously they're enhancing it the guys
to be like insane martial arts here but
maybe they might include a little bit of
that mythos to him that people believed
him to be capable of as well as you know
killing him off in this movie but doing
it in the way that does kind of line up
with how his body actually was
discovered or maybe though inglorious
basterds this thing and just do a whole
new version of how they took out
Rasputin I heard Aaron taylor-johnson
supposed to be in this film I didn't see
if you guys have a moment like a
timestamp in the trailer you can tell me
he happens to appear I would love to
know that because I mean Aaron
taylor-johnson was in kick-ass Matthew
Vaughn directed so I'm excited for the
fact that he's returning to another
Matthew Vaughn joint annual brawl in
Djimon Honsou
two people from the MCU crossing over
into here but Djimon Honsou you know he
he is like the comic book presence keys
in Constantine is Papa midnite he's in
guardians of the galaxy as Korath he's
in Shazam as the wizard I feel like
there's
another one I'm missing you know even
Kingsman I gotta say I'm excited for ray
Fiennes to be doing this I feel like it
could do something for him in the way
how people were impressed with how Colin
Firth is able to do a great action role
so damn well and I feel like there's no
doubt that ray Fiennes can pull it off
and forgive me if I can't recall
something right off hand ups and they
did was action based Voldemort does not
count okay wanting it but I'm really
excited to see what he does in an action
role they says come out September 18th
so I mean I guess it's only competition
it really has coming a little bit after
that would be Wonder Woman now I know
Kingsman the Golden Circle did
underperform some people really didn't
like that movie I personally had a lot
of fun watching it I still think the
actual you know Kingsman franchise would
that be a pasta free after the G
deserves a proper sequel they would be
cool that if the eggsy series got like a
full trilogy in and of itself i really
hope people give this a chance
and also Rhys offense as Rasputin Rhys
Ifans
is a highly underrated actor he deserves
to be way more famous he really he
deserves to be so much more famous to
the point that I should know if I'm
pronouncing his name right or wrong
because I really don't think I'm
pronouncing it right Rhys Ifans
the first movie I saw him in was Notting
Hill he's hilarious and their
replacements and you know he's dr. Curt
Connors in the Amazing Spiderman and
he's Xenophilius in the Harry Potter
movies
what Xenophilius and ray Fiennes volta
more crawl my god crossovers we love
that she any him talk along nope
this looks great looks like a really fun
film and I'm definitely gonna be there
opening night assuming it does stick to
its release date
let's hope Tennant does well everything
is riding on that all right guys what do
you think of this Kingsman trailer leave
your thoughts down below subscribe to
the real rejects please click that
notification bell hope you're having a
good Father's Day last but not least
I want to shout out Jason Dolan today
now Jason Dolan is a beautiful beautiful
human being great friend of mine
actually he's someone who lives in
Atlanta right now when he first moved
back home it's primarily to take care of
his father so and honor father's day I
want her to wish your father Jason Dolan
a Happy Father's Day because he is
blessed to have such a wonderful son as
you now the question is when are you
gonna be a father Jason I mean you're a
very very talented writer you're
venturing into directing right now and
now wondering you know it's only a
matter of time before you're able to put
a ring around someone's finger and get
yourself a baby maybe he'll come out
bald just like you he should if he has a
full head of hair
your baby is mutated this started off
sweet and now it's gone wrong you've
been a great friend to me Jason I hope
one day you get to be a great father I
hope you have triplets and then followed
by an anxiety attack and then followed
by them of you abandoning them so that
way they could learn to be strong
without you I'm sorry I can't maintain
sincerity with you you're Jason Dolan
what do you have for me